let's bring in Tony Boselli Westwood one
analyst and sideline reporter for Super
Bowl 50 for Tony how are you today I'm
good
keep on going Brady talk in the game and
can't we enjoy just one super I love Tom
Brady greatest one of greatest ever but
can we not enjoy one Super Bowl without
him instead of bringing them in to how
you were to save the day for the 49ers
of you two been there nope we can't do
it Tony
not possible yeah Thomas always in our
thoughts I the most important play of
last night was what well I think it's a
certain 15 I think that was huge up to
that point obviously the long past the
tire came up to that point San Francisco
really just shut down
mahomes he was frustrated series before
you throwing the pick I felt like going
to third and 15 player there was not a
doubt in my mind the 49ers were getting
off the field in getting the ball and
probably salt in the game away and when
you completed that passion felt the
change in the stadium coated on the
sidelines and then you add to the fact
that I thought that series after they
score in Kyle Shannon in first down five
yard game so you get a second of five
and I thought run it run it get a first
down calm things down and they decide to
go to the pass now in fairness the
college getting ripped for calling a
pass they're born is wide open and it's
just a good play by Chris Jones he
knocks it down he's you know at the line
of scrimmage so those kind of two series
of events right there long pass you know
kind of the three now afterwards that's
when you felt like he not going to be
the Niners day I felt the same way that
and we just had rahim most heard on and
he said look I'm a team player I would
like to have the ball there if I'm gonna
go I can run clock maybe you take a
timeout or two away from Kansas City and
maybe I get a first down there you know
worst case scenario I might run a
bootleg with Garoppolo just to Surprise
them and then he slides if he you know
he's gonna get tackled but I gotta I
have to have the clock running a little
bit I got to put a little bit more
pressure on the homes about when he gets
on the field this might be the last time
you get on the field and you better
score
touchdown there I thought the Niners did
that for almost the entire game except
for the final 8 minutes and I set it
onto here last night they came down the
sideline Kurt and I are talking about I
was shocked I mean you're sitting there
you've the number 2 this is just like an
average rushing team this isn't the
49ers who you know have a bouquet line
ok back this is the second best group of
the NFL and I was sure and everything he
said they were going to run the ball and
go down and solve this thing you know
get a first down at least he's doing men
on there and it's just that you know
five yards in first I mean yeah that's a
you know offensively in the NFL if you
get four plus yards and first down
you won and they did it and for whatever
reason Kyle decided he wanted to drop
back and throw it yeah I don't know if
if Kyle because we had this problem with
the Falcons and the Superbowl with the
Patriots where you think they're gonna
run then they don't run I have a lot
more confidence in Matt Ryan throwing
the football than I do Jimmy Garoppolo
now I've amplified that pressure on him
when he got to third and five I thought
oh my god he's got the weight of the
entire Super Bowl right now on this
might be the most important throw of his
career and the thing that was really
interesting to me is they had never they
really weren't effective drop back
passing all night I mean if you look at
when Bravo was successful who was on the
naked there's on the RPO there's off the
run action and and so the he they were
sent in them in the stadium that bike
hey core pose is on today they can throw
it they can get in the rhythm with the
passing game and that's why at the
biggest moment why do you go there
especially I'm gonna repeat myself this
is a team that threw eight times to get
to the Super Bowl this is a team that
had her back we most had 200 plus yards
in the NFC champion touch the ball until
the second quarter well you and you have
some of these well coaches will out
think themselves or outsmart themselves
we saw that would Seattle at the goal
line with Marshawn Lynch you saw that
with the Falcons against the Patriots
and then all of a sudden last night and
I I just thought that you're gonna give
him another chance and it felt like that
defense was starting to question how
long they could hold this damn before
the water burst and and you saw that it
took a long time and they really
frustrated my homes I I it felt like he
was out of sorts but it felt like he he
was having the worst game of his career
and and he probably had the worst game
of his career or at least close to it
anyone who he wanted Super Bowl and won
the MVP well I was you know start
thinking of what's going to happen and
at 20 to 10 yet seven minutes left third
and 15 you're like okay you say you
start thinking about what am I going to
say postgame about you know about the
49ers and and what they did and
everything was gonna be about the
defense and how you know Robert Sala and
that group you know did something
similar to what the Giants did to the
Patriots in Super Bowl 42 when the
Patriots are the best offense in
football and for guys who could rush the
passer disrupt Brady and changed the
game because that's what was happening
it was the four-man front that was
absolutely getting after the homes he
had no time and that was the narrative
that was the story except for 21 points
in six minutes at the end of the game
changed everything
talking to Tony Boselli Westwood one
analyst the former all-pro for the Jags
I know you you've talked about it you
thought about it maybe you're trying to
forget about it but I was rooting for
you for the Hall of Fame as you're a
finalist once again I I don't know if
you're inching closer or not but I saw
you talking to John Lynch and although
we you know I'm trying to lip-read there
I'm guessing you're discussing being
Hall of Fame finalists and not getting
in
yeah when we talked about a lot about
the game you know coming up and then
obviously we talked about you know I was
in seventh year being a finalist my
fourth neither of us got and both of us
were in the top ten again and you know
we just talked about you know stay
positive had hit up and in both of us
you know we played against each other
and we've known each other we know the
kind of player the players each of us
were and I looked at that today
maybe just meant to be John next in
Tampa you played motion Campa who you
got clear you get in and maybe you can
drag me along this Dan it's frustrating
I mean the competitor enough all you
want to be there it's you know really I
don't want say it validates your career
but it doesn't want sense at a higher
level about you know kind of who you
were but I'll say this this year was
different for me in the sense of a
number of guys I played against or the
most vocal they ever were about me
deserving to be in the whole thing and
then guys who already in the whole thing
saying stuff like that and when you're
play off the line think about it there's
no stats you know there's nothing that
you and your crew there can say hey look
at how many of this he did
I mean triple-doubles you had or how
many you know thousand yard rushing or
passing there's none of that it's it's a
bunch of big guys just being violent
with other big guys and trying to stop
people from hurting your teammates and
there's no way that it's hard to measure
and so I always say the biggest
compliment and this is taking nothing
away from the voters the ultimate
compliment is that they vote men but
when guys I played against and guys were
in the whole family played against when
they say I was the best or one the best
ever I mean that's that's pretty special
so I will see what happens you never
know it's a one of those things and you
have a good life good like I said on
Twitter a good life good family good
friends and yes I want to be a Hall of
Famer but if it doesn't happen like it
did this year everyone's still going to
love
I think you're the Terrell Davis of
offensive lineman yeah that's I mean one
of the things I am getting a little bit
tired of is this the you know short
career conversation I'm like wait a
second you guys like put that to the
long time ago yeah number one Gale
Sayers played much less much for your
game tonight at any point earrings
knighted
Dwight's team is an offensive lineman
played four games and I bid who's a
great center to hurt Terrell Davis
latest played fewer games and I bid can
he easily just got in recently played
for your games and I did and so I like
what I want to say is like you can't use
that anymore now just judge it based on
was I the best of what I did when I play
and if I was them to me that's a
hall-of-famer
if I wasn't okay okay then it is what it
is but don't the short career stuff has
to go away because the precedent has
been set in my opinion we're celebrating
next year Tony I like it I'm with it you
know I was disappointed this year Dan
but I did not get over the last few
years and I thought maybe it was a good
thing because maybe this is what was
going to give me the ball fame like the
last three years I've been invited on
set
you know the Super Bowl week to come on
the show this year I didn't get to
invite I'm thinking maybe Dan knows
something like that he's not going to
invite me on because I'm getting in so I
was okay with it at the time down a
little bit down because uh I didn't get
in so you didn't help it's my point so
we'll have to figure this whole thing
out well what's more disappointing not
getting the Hall of Fame or not getting
invited on the show next year next year
we're celebrating and thank you buddy
safe travels back and thanks for joining
us thank you and that's Tony be selling
Westwood one analyst former Jags all-pro
four more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]